[Music]
i
on a please
[Music]
baby take my hands
[Music]
[Music]
oh
i love you so much
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
time after time
i've done my sentence
[Music]
but committed no crime
and bad mistakes
[Music]
i've made a few
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
till
[Music]
we the champions
of the world
[Music]
you brought me fame and fortune and
everything that goes with it
[Music]
i consider it a challenge
[Music]
my friends
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my friends
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
girls
ah
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
who's the owner
[Music]
tell
i'm not me it
there is
[Music]
i wonder
[Music]
potato
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
tell your children
in the house
[Music]
[Music]
train
ladies and gentlemen the president
of the united states donald j trump
ladies and gentlemen the president
of the united states donald j
trump
ladies and gentlemen the president
of the united states donald j
trump
where at least i know i'm free
and i won't forget the men who died
who gave that light to me and i gladly
stand up
next
[Music]
land god bless
the usa
[Music]
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas from
sea to shining sea
[Music]
from detroit down to houston
and new york
where there's pride in every american
heart
that
[Music]
an is where it is
[Music]
thank you very much thank you very much
appreciate it and hello rochester
great to be with you four days from now
we're going to win
the state of minnesota
[Applause]
and i did not forget you because we're
given a very very hard time by your
so-called leaders but they're not very
good leaders as you found out
during the riots and we're going to win
four more years in our great white house
thank you
as you know there are at least 25 000
people
who wanted to be here tonight we just
saw
a lot of them wanted to pay our respects
they were here for a long time they
waited and waited and
then the governor did bad things
your far left democrat attorney general
keith ellison
and your democrat governor tried to shut
down our rally
silence the people of minnesota and take
away your freedom
and your rights
[Music]
they thought he would cancel a word they
are very familiar with cancel
cancel culture but i said no way
i will never abandon the people of
minnesota
i will come up i will come
thousands and thousands of people over
there with cars we flew over cars they
go miles long
what a shame they waited here for a long
time
i want to thank the thousands of people
outside who were barred from entry
by radical democrats you are
american patriots thank you very much
[Applause]
when large numbers of rioters and
vandals sack
the city of minneapolis earlier this
year keith ellison
did not ask them to submit a permit
he told the throngs of violent
demonstrators
by all means exercise your first
amendment rights
he said that prior to them ripping down
your city
keith ellison sided with flag-burning
extremists over law-abiding americans
he treats you like second-class citizens
he believes that the pro-american voters
have fewer rights than anti-american
demonstrators
keith ellison and joe biden want to
imprison you in your homes while letting
anarchists
agitators and vandals roam free
as they destroy your cities and states
the democrat party wants you to be
banned
from peaceful assembly while they allow
their supporters to burn down
a police precinct right here
biden and the far left incite violence
with their vile
anti-police rhetoric and the fact that
they're weak
people very very weak people they allow
rioters to lay waste to the public
streets that
financed and they were financed by you
with your hard-earned taxpayer dollars
the radical left is determined to
obliterate the middle class
they think they can take your money
attack your values
indoctrinate your children and silence
your voices but on november 3rd
i hope you're listening minnesota
because this is what you've had to put
up with for a long time
the people of our nation are going to be
heard like never before it's already
begun
people are already starting to find out
what's happening
because they're going to show up and
vote in record numbers
and you have already started to see
what's going on
and they're getting very concerned we're
not just running against
sleepy joe biden we're running against
the arrogant far left
[Music]
wing democrats treat law enforcement
like criminals
and they treat criminals like heroes
they lecture you on morality while they
support sanctuary cities against
innocent americans
named they ban you from
going to church while they left
left-wing extremists burning down
while their own jobs remain totally
exact
they keep your kids out of school while
their families hire
prosecutors they flood your cities with
illegal threats and gangs while they
live inside
waldorf compounds they want to destroy
work hard to destroy the suburbs which
unprotected
and terminating horrible rules and
regulations that only pertain to each
other
will they move into stated communities
these wealthy liberal hypocrites want to
defund the police
to take the gun
while they are protected by armed
there's stars one way to defend your
dignity
there's only one way to defend your
family and your country
there's only one way to preserve father
defend
the american way of life we must show
up and vote on november 3rd
in the second term we will increase
funding for law enforcement
we will hire more tougher and current
prosecutors to put
violence offenders behind bars we will
finish and win
the war against msa created killings
we've taken thousands out of our country
[Music]
and we will reclaim our streets for a
law-abiding americans of every race
color religion country these are streets
that have been run by democrats
not republicans and it's taken too long
for them to gain
control of their streets
running for too long you want law
and order and
on november 3rd vote to defeat joe biden
and save your great american dream
and
[Music]
a lot of people have known it for a long
time he's done nothing but betrayed you
for 47 years all he's done
in that time is sell out your lobbyists
sell out with china
by their own sell out the big farmer
and sell out the foreign country he will
look you in the eye
and then turn right around and stab you
in the back and be totally protected by
the mainstream media the only thing
he cares about his political power and
he will use that power to hurt you and
to enrich his cronies and his friends
and most of all to enrich his family and
mostly joe biden is a vote to put far
left radicals like keith ellison and
theohan omar
and aoc plus three
and gun grammar better overall wants to
take the guns away
once you destroy your second amendment
into capital positions
controlling the entire federal
government and then they want to pass
the courts
they want to tax those courts the
supreme court they want to put
radical justices who will constitute
your gun
terminate your religious liberty erase
all of your borders and stifle life
if you want strong borders strong
families
safe communities and a thriving economy
and i am asking you to go out on my
membership
and vote for your all-time favorite
president
[Music]
[Music]
one
thank you
[Music]
one of the most crucial issues for
minnesota
in this election is the subject of
refugees
this is security
to protect our country i issued a
directive suspending the
entry of refugees from our nation
compromised by terrorism terrorism like
you've never seen before
including from syria somalia
and yemen
they're keeping radical obamacare
out of our time i spoke to president
over the last four days with terrorist
attacks
from the most dangerous and violent
terrorist hospital
anywhere in the world who is also vowed
to terminate our national
allowing for unlimited migration from
war zones and terrorist havens he said
bring them in buy these deadly migration
policies
will overwhelm the minnesota and
overwhelmed taxpayers and open the
floodgates to terrorists
and violent extremists under my
administration the safety of our
families will always come first
american place our family
with your support we will continue to
bring back your jobs
cut your taxes cut regulations support
our
great police support our military defend
our borders
protect our second amendment which is
totally under siege but don't worry
as long as i'm here nothing's happening
with it
protect religious liberty and ensure
more products are proudly stamped with
the very wonderful and beautiful phrase
made in the usa
yesterday it was announced that last
quarter our economy grew
at the fastest rate ever recorded
history of our country
33.1 people were shocked
i wasn't biggest increase in the history
of our country
by far 1952 but it was a rate
less than half we are creating an
economic
powerhouse a superpower the likes of
which the world has never seen before
we are building the biggest strongest
and most prosperous middle class
in human history and i am fighting for
higher wages
more jobs more opportunity and we will
keep
it right there and we will bring it
right here to the usa
where it belongs
joe biden has never succeeded before
barack obama said that if you want to
see things screwed up
just ask joe biden to do it joe biden
will ship your factories to china
impose a four trillion dollar tax hike
eliminate private health care
abolish the entire oil industry and
fracking
and send your state into a crippling
depression barton's anti-energy
anti-worker policies would be a
nightmare for latino and
african-american workers all across our
land
biden will also continue his 47 years of
cruelly betraying african americans he
called them
super predators in 1994
ripped apart their communities and did
everything in his power to wipe
out the black middle class and they
understand it
better than anybody and i think you'll
probably see that
at the voter booth they understand what
he's done
better than anybody super predators he
said
now biden wants to wipe out the entire
u.s economy
for black americans hispanic americans
and all americans
he has no idea what he's doing he wants
to give you the largest
tax increase in the history of our
country by far
joe biden's plan will delay the vaccine
postpone
therapies crash the economy and shut
down
our entire country under the
lockdown which he talks about and
cherishes
countless americans will die from
suicide
drug overdoses and deferred medical care
at a level like you haven't seen before
there will be no school no graduations
no weddings no thanksgiving
no christmas no fourth of july no easter
no nothing there will be no future for
america's youth
under my plan we will deliver a safe
vaccine to the american people in just a
matter of weeks
and it will be something that will be
very very special
and we are rounding the turn on the
pandemic
with or without vaccine we have the
vaccine it's going to come
but even without it we're rounding the
turn seniors will be first in line to
get it
and it will be available free wasn't
their fault
it wasn't our fault it was the fault of
china
we should have kept it within their
limits our vaccine will eradicate the
virus
and the pandemic and it will end quickly
restore
normal life that's what we want is
normal life take us back
seven months normal life record
setting everything and a normal life and
next year will be the greatest economic
year in the history of our country
[Applause]
we will wipe out the china plague once
and for all
we're joined today by congressman jim
hagedorn
and congressman tom emmer thank you
fellas thank you very much
thank you very much thanks jim tom great
warriors have been with me all the way
and congressional candidates somebody
that's really outstanding i think you
two agree right you two agree
michelle fishbach
great job i saw you in the debate you
did a fantastic job thank you michelle
great job
state senator paul gazelka paul thank
you
thank you paul state representative
kurt dowd thank you
thank you thank you kurt like your hat
and gop chair jennifer carnahan
thank you jennifer are we doing well
jennifer
i think we're going to win 1972
and you have been treated very very
badly in addition
friend of mine mike lindell thank you
very much thank you mike
thank you very much great job great job
and foreign oh this is a big one really
matt burke minnesota viking star
superstar really huh
look at him look like he could play
tomorrow thank you very much matt great
honor to meet you
another vital issue in this race is the
minnesota iron range i brought it back
to life
it was dead it was closed it was sealed
and you weren't going to use it for
anything as vice president joe biden
tried to obliterate the iron range seven
plants were idled the rest were closing
very shortly
and they were bad there was barely a
whimper
i brought the iron range roaring back to
life i have friends that live in
minnesota they said it was so unfair
when it was closed a man came up to me i
don't know who he was but he was a
strong
big powerful man and he was crying and
he said they've taken my
life away when they closed the iron
range well i opened it that was the most
convincing of all everybody wanted me to
do it
but when i saw him i said there's no
doubt about it and it's fully opened and
read and really
doing phenomenally and it has the best
iron they say
anywhere in the world but you had it
closed so it's great
congratulations congratulations
it was my honor that area is now
thriving it's thriving it was
desolate it's now thriving nine democrat
mayors in the iron range have endorsed
me
because they know biden will shut down
the iron reigns forever and by the way
they will shut it down as fast as i
opened it up and they'll shut it down
permanently the next time they said we
made a mistake
we didn't do it through nature we made a
mistake
uh they will shut it down permanently so
i hope you remember that
i just hope you remember that especially
on november third
under my leadership we achieved the most
secure border in american history
biden's plan to admit unlimited low wage
foreign workers will slash
income surge unemployment and devastate
your middle class
all to enrich his globalist donors he
raises money like crazy because he's
making deals they're giving him millions
of dollars
i could raise much more than him but i
don't want to be compromised i won't be
compromised
and we don't need the money we don't
need the money that's how they've raised
all of that money because they're making
deals with wall street
as president i will only advance
immigration policies that put american
workers and families first
you the american people are my only
special interests that's why i did this
and i had a very nice life before doing
this i have to tell you
i will continue fighting for you harder
than anyone has ever done before
the forgotten men and women of our
country will never ever be forgotten
again
and you know that and you saw that four
years ago we had a very very exciting
time this is even more exciting and
frankly
this is a more important election and i
never thought i'd be saying that
a vote for me and the republican party
is a vote for
the american dream so minnesota this is
that very important time has finally
arrived
this is it this is the history of our
nation
this is a very very big moment for our
country
this tuesday or sooner get out
and vote every one of you
remember what your governor did this
evening
and it's a small thing but a horrible
thing to thousands and thousands of
people that are
outside that could be here we could all
be together
a horrible thing that they did your
state and your country
depend on you we depend on your vote
we depend on your loyalty and you have
my loyalty
that you know and that you found out
[Applause]
together we are going to make history on
november 3rd we're going to make history
and this will be very special
for minnesota people have been talking
about it for years but it never quite
works out
even with me we lost by half a point
one more stop i should have come one
more time
just one more time but you know what
it's not going to matter
because we're going to have an even
bigger victory on november 3rd
so i want to thank you god bless you god
bless minnesota
and god bless america thank you for
being here
we appreciate it thank you thank you
everybody thank you
thank you mike thank you everybody nice
seeing you matt
good job thank you everybody
[Music]
[Music]
young man
cause you're in a new town there's no
need
to be unhappy
and i'm sure you will find many ways
[Music]
[Applause]
they have everything
is
[Music]
what do you wanna
[Music]
all by himself
it's funny
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's hard to
[Music]
you can do whatever you'll
[Music]
[Music]
ymca they can't stop
it's fun to stay at the mca
it's fun
is
pick yourself off the ground
[Music]
ymca
why
[Music]
wow
[Music]
blue
[Music]
seamstress for the band
[Music]
[Music]
music man
[Music]
dancing in the sun
she's in me
always with me
tiny dancing in my hand
[Music]
jesus freaked
out in the street
and then tickets out for gone
turning back
[Music]
she's just laughs
the full of lord is
[Music]
in their auditorium
[Music]
[Music]
with no one near only you
and you can't hear me
when i say softly
[Music]
slowly
[Music]
on the highway
[Music]
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
do
[Music]
seems to score the band
[Music]
you marry a music man
[Music]
now she's in me
always with me
tiny dancer in my head
[Music]
you and you can hear
me when i say softly
[Music]
[Music]
slowly
[Music]
him
[Music]
today
[Music]
him
[Music]
dance
[Music]
um yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]